Brandteig ist total vielseitig und ich
zeige dir wie du ih ganz einfach
herstellst dafür nimmst du etwas Butter
Wasser und Salz lässt das Ganze
aufkochen dann kommt das Mehl in einem
Schwung mit dazu und dieser Teig wird
dann im Topf abgebrannt bis sich am
Boden ein weißer Belag bildet und jetzt
rührst du ein Ei nach dem anderen ein
zuerst bildet sich kein schöner
homogener Teig aber je mehr Eier du dazu
gibst umso besser wird der Teig wir
geben aber nur so viele mit dazu bis der
Teig schön glänzt und beim Herausziehen
des Löffels schöne Spitzen formt aus
diesem Teig könnt ihr jetzt Windbeutel
Eclairs oder auch
profeterolspritzen jetzt wird's im Ofen
gebacken nach dem Backen kurz abkühlen
lassen und dann nach Belieben füllen